the entire left world mobilized
immediately
you had joe biden
who rushed to twitter to tweet out using
two fingers because that's how he do it
he tweeted out what happened today to
jesse's melies must never be tolerated
in this country
we must stand up and demand that we no
longer give this hate safe harbor that
homophobia and racism have no place on
our streets or in our hearts we are with
you as you see and um
i have good news
homophobia and racism had no place on
our streets because the attacker of
juicy similier
is going to prison meanwhile kamala
harris when she wasn't trying to bail
out rioters in the middle of the blm
riots
that would be just a little while later
this is twenty this is january 2019.
she tweets out
jesse smolit is one of the kindest most
gentle human beings i know
well not to jesse as it turns out he was
not so kind or gentle to jesse i'm
praying for his quick recovery this was
an attempted modern day lynching by the
way this tweet is still up no one should
have to fear for their life because of
their sexuality or color of their skin
we must confront this hate it was an
attempt in modern day lynching by jesse
smilette against jesse smellette
such lynchings have to end
nancy pelosi who now has deleted this
tweet she tweeted the racist homophobic
attack and justice
is an affront to our humanity
no one should be attacked for who they
are or whom they love i pray that jesse
has a speedy recovery and that justice
is served may we all commit to ending
this hate
once and for all
also moving so moving
maxine waters
who uh
has yet to find a race riot that she
doesn't love she tweeted out jesse is my
friend a very talented and beautiful
human being
so she's wrong on both of those things
he is not talented and he is not a
beautiful human being it is so hurtful
that homophobic haters would dare hurt
someone so loving
and giving
of checks to nigerian immigrants
to
beat him up
i'm dedicated to finding the culprits
and bringing them to justice
i have some good news maxine
her search was not in vain she was
dedicated like o.j simpson to finding
the real killer
she was dedicated to finding the
culprits and bringing them to justice
jesse did not deserve to be harmed by
anyone again i have good news he was not
harmed by anyone so that's good
dedicated to finding the culprits and
bringing them to justice by the way has
matching waters ever said this about you
know an innocent black person killed by
a black person which is the vast
majority of black people who are killed
in this country because it turns out
that intra-racial crime is significantly
more common than interracial crime
okay and then um there was bernie bernie
sounded off we could do this all day
gang i got all the receipts today bernie
sanders tweeted the racist and
homophobic attack on justice blood is a
horrific instance of the surging
hostility to minorities around the
country we must come together to have to
take all forms of bigotry and violence
here's the thing
the supply of racism and bigotry in
america is so low and the demand on the
left is so high that even a completely
false ridiculous on its face story like
this had to be treated as gospel truth
by the entire left top to bottom side to
side i mean everyone everyone any
expression of doubt was tantamount to a
form of heresy
he tweeted out while the struggle for
basic hate crime legislation continues
here in indiana this horrible attack
calls all americans to stand against
hatred and violence in all of its forms
i'd finish this tweet but i'm on
paternity leave
and then of course there was kirsten
gillibrand
the the the one-time presidential
candidate i say one time because it
literally was one time it was like for a
minute she tweeted this is a sickening
an outrageous attack and horribly it's
the latest of too many hate crimes
against lgbtq plus iaa backslash colon
little squiggly thing tilde over the end
that said that turns nina into nina in
spanish
people and people of color we are all
responsible for condemning this behavior
and every person who enables or
normalizes it praying for jesse and his
family
we are all responsible for condemning
this behavior and every person who
enables or normalizes it who has enabled
or normalized this behavior kirsten
jollibrand who would enable or normalize
race hoax behavior who
who would do such a thing kirsten
gillibrand
who
and then the irrepressible
the fresh so fresh
so face
freshly mcface head
alexandra ocasio-cortez representative
from twitch
she tweeted
there is no there's an there's a
headline from entertainment today that
said jesse smallett has been
hospitalized in chicago after a possible
homophobic and racially charged attack
and she said there is no such thing as
racially charged this attack was not
possibly homophobic it was racist and
homophobic
if you don't like what is happening to
our country work to change it it's no
one's job to water down or sugarcoat the
rise of hate crimes
also here i am sugar-coating
anti-semitism
uh rashida talib sound it off as well
uh
when one of the most famous black and
gay men in america is not safe the
message is clearer than it ever has been
she was quoting an article from gq
the dangerous lies spewing from the
right wing is killing and hurting our
people thinking of you jesse smilet and
my
lgbtq plus i a plus l u y dollar sign
neighbors
the dangerous lies of spewing from the
right wing is killing and hurting i feel
like that was not the lie here but you
needed to tell it didn't you didn't you
we'll get some more on this in just one
second first let me tell you about the
best christmas gift of the season it is
the new kamakoto japanese steel knife
because these things are just
spectacular kamakoto makes great
japanese steel kitchen knives using
traditional techniques from japan that
have been honed and perfected by
generations of knife smiths kamakoto
only uses steel sourced from the mills
in japan their expert bladesmiths forge
and shape raw steel into hearty blades
polishing and sharpening them to an
excruciatingly fine edge each knife
comes in a beautiful heavy-duty ash wood
box and makes sure that the knife is
stored safely it also makes kamikota a
great gift kamakoto is so confident
about their knives that each knife comes
with a lifetime guarantee because of the
single bevel edge kamakoto knives can
achieve an unbelievably sharp edge you
just can't get with other knives they
can cut through your rib eye like butter
okay so i'm a big fan of making myself
an omelette for lunch and let me just
tell you every time i slice through an
onion with these things it just it's
magical it's a magical experience they
look great they're unbelievably durable
they're beautifully weighted beautifully
balanced kamikoto is currently having a
massive holiday sale on top of that sale
you can get an additional 50 bucks off
any purchase you make with discount code
ben shapiro so click the link below or
go to kamakoto.com
ben shapiro use promo code ben shapiro
save an extra 50 today
okay and then of course you have the
activist group you had color of change
which issued a statement at the time
saying that the attack was a reminder of
the real violence black lgbtq people
face every day well um it's not a
reminder so much of the real violence
that they they face every day as a
reminder of the fake violence that they
hate that they face every day because it
turns out that he was lying and pretty
obviously lying
glad put out a statement at the time
saying jesse's experience is sadly not
unique in today's america by the way
that's true race hoaxes happen on a
fairly regular basis in the united
states right now because the incentive
structure is very much in favor of race
hoaxes
this has been happening like a lot in
the like shockingly a lot in the united
states this doesn't mean that there
aren't hate crimes doesn't mean there
isn't interracial crime white on black
although interracial crime black on
white is significantly more common
the the race cross the race hoax issue
is a real issue
and pretending that it's not
is ignoring the state of play in the
country okay and then of course you had
the entire celebrity class
he had ariana grande
we tweeted out what happened to jesse
makes me really effing sick to my
stomach i can't believe bleep like this
is really still happening every day i
can't i can't believe it either because
number one it's not really happening
every day and also because it's not so
that what kind of world question mark
sending all of the healing energy slash
love i possibly can and hoping for
change what can we do tell me and i'm
there well you could you know not help
propagate a lie shonda rhymes she
tweeted we all have a responsibility to
rise up against the ignorance and hate
out there if you know who did this to
jesse smilet report them to police i'm
on it
i'm on it
i know who did this to jesse smallette
kerry washington tweeted dear
god
she stares up to the heavens tears
pouring down her face why oh god why
prayers and justice
for jesus
uh justice came for jesse smilier but
not in the be careful what you wish for
zendaya
tweeted out this is terrifying and
heartbreaking please pay attention to
what's happening here well the problem
is we kind of did that was the problem
in this story because juicy probably
thought okay well i'll tell my tail
maybe i won't even go to the cops
and then it'll all be like i was a hero
and then everybody was like well you
know when you do that we pay really
close attention and he's like well
then you get the homer simpson gif of
him just like backing into a bush
reverend al sharpton who uh
is always a plausible source when it
comes to the veracity of interracial
hate crimes it's not like al sharpton
who still has a show on msnbc it's not
like he
actively propagated the lie that a
manhattan d.a
raped
an underage black girl and then scrawled
racial slurs on her in feces back in the
1980s
that'd be the tawanna browley hoax
al sharpton would never be complicit in
something like that so i take his
judgment
really that he has solid judgment on
what is true and what is false when it
comes to race hoaxes
he tweeted out at the time the reported
hate attack on my friend and brother
after jesse smelled is despicable and
outrageous the guilty must face the
maximum
i come bearing glad tidings reverend al
the guilty must face the maximum
viola davis tweeted omg
double exclamation point this is why the
lgbtq plus i-a-o-p
open bracket close bracket backslash
double quotation mark
carrot
little weird thing above the option
button
this is why that community continues to
fight to be seen and protected against
hate we all have to take this racist and
homophobic attack to violence very
personally my arms are around you jesse
smith you are loved well the good news
for jesse smith is that justice
mallettes arms were also around jossey's
malette when jesse smallett was
attacking jesse smilet in the middle of
a hate crime against jesse smallett
ellen's generous tweeted about it and
i'm sending him and his family so much
love today so much love shares was
pretty great sure tweeted out
the best thing about shara's twitter
account is that she's so clearly drunk
when she writes these tweets
like the cap slot goes on and she's you
have to imagine when chair tweets these
things that the caps lock button goes on
and she knows about halfway through the
tweet that it's on she's like oh
emoji so here's what she tweeted jesse
smallett empire actor reportedly
attacked impossible hate crime npr
villainy
racism
oh
my
promoted by most infamous clown clown
emoji in world emoji is the poison that
kills american flag
period no space white only is not right
period
american flag is poopoo of color praying
hands
gop goes down
with ship
ggt
small digiti
ah cher it's that sort of insight
that um that makes you such a wondrous
addition to america's political
discourse
so you had the entire political
infrastructure that came to jucy's
defense you had the entire entertainment
defense
he had prominent members of the media
who were helping out as it turns out don
lemon was texting with juicy and telling
jucy that the police didn't believe him
which seems to be kind of a violation of
journalistic ethics you had places like
gq writing articles titled the racist
homophobic attack on juicy smoothie is
america's end game
end game
and by the way they didn't present it as
an opinion piece originally it presented
it as just a journalistic piece then
later they were like oh yeah it's an
opinion piece the editor's notes on this
are pretty spectacular the editor's note
2 22 in the original version of this
piece
gq made two errors in editorial judgment
we failed to clearly present the post as
an opinion piece
and we regret applying unfounded
political motivations to then breaking
news with the original headline
we have altered the headline
juicy update jesse smalley was arrested
update the story is fast moving we're
keeping an eye on the news as it
develops whoopsie doodle but again the
entire piece is predicated on the idea
that juicy sommelier is representative
of black men in america and gay men in
america and none of that is true
none of that is true but that was the
narrative that's why they did this if it
were not a narrative story it wouldn't
matter
and by the way it is important to
remember that juicy was part and parcel
of the left-wing infrastructure okay he
was a very political actor he was always
political and he kind of fell out of
prominence because the obamas were no
longer in office and so him hanging out
with michelle obama just wasn't the same
but i mean this is a guy who literally
went dancing with michelle obama right
this is a person who was very political
i mean here's some video of him dancing
with michelle obama back in 2018. ah how
the how the mighty have fallen here he
was dancing with michelle obama one year
before he faked a hate crime against
himself
[Music]
by the way it didn't it wasn't just that
he danced with michelle obama as it
turns out
at the time
tina chen's longtime friend was not
surprised that the former obama
administration aide helped connect
justice smelly's family with a top
illinois prosecutor weeks before a grand
jury indicted smilet on the theory he
falsely reported being the victim of a
hate crime relatives of the actor had
expressed to tina chen concerns about
the investigation by chicago pd
getting the right person to take those
sorts of concerns seriously has been a
hallmark of tina chen's career
highlighted by a stint as then first
lady michelle obama's chief of staff
so she reached out michelle obama's
chief of staff to prosecutors to try and
work on behalf of jessie smallette
chen said her contact with kim fox on
behalf of smart's family was not
intended to influence the case outcome
oh sure it wasn't
shortly after millett reported he was
attacked as a family friend i contacted
cook county state's attorney kim fox who
i also know from prior work together she
said
my sole activity was to put the chief
prosecutor in the case in touch with an
alleged victim's family who had concerns
about how the investigation was being
characterized in public
so um
that was how tied in jesse smallett was
what to do to the infrastructure
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed